I'm so [ __ ] depressed I [ __ ] hate
my life my dad thinks I'm a piece of
[ __ ]
I've never accomplished anything cuz
he's the [ __ ] CEO Microsoft and I'm a
dumb germ I can't go out yeah I want
friends I want to be friends with people
do you know what it's like you know
Hardee's to go to a party when your
cousin is SARS yeah my cousin SARS I'd
love to meet this old [ __ ] my dad is
Bill Gates my mother's a bat you think
your family's [ __ ] up I wake up every
day there's another [ __ ] news story
it's not true I'm trying to help these
people
they're [ __ ] stupid people saying I
live in farts what kind of fucked-up
[ __ ] is that did I live in someone's ass
Hall Candice Owen says even believe I'm
real let me catch that [ __ ] let me
catch that [ __ ] into Whole Foods I'll
go write up for knows you will not be
able to transmit me to humans but I
haven't affected you my dad's always
like yeah we're gonna we're gonna
[ __ ] we're gonna give you to every
single person that's what my dad wants
to do what's it put a little bit of me
in a needle and give it to eight billion
people what do you think that does to my
sense of self I'm [ __ ] real deal you
don't even know how I'm gonna affect you
nobody knows I might like your body I
might not I'm going to some of these
bodies I'm like get me the [ __ ] out of
here has anyone ever asked me what the
[ __ ] I want to do with my life I want to
be something I would have a lifestyle
brand I would have a clothing line maybe
nobody's asked me that nobody asked me
to be in a [ __ ] tick-tock nobody
wants to all up here - tick tock week
over 19 no one wants that
so just [ __ ] alone all the time I
wish I was AIDS